The biggest story,
really, probably,
while we were off
for these five months
was Trump being put on trial--
or he's gonna have--
he's got four trials.
He's got a "I gave hush money
to a porn star" trial.
He's got a
"I stole documents and put them
by the toilet" trial.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
He has a "I asked
for 11,000 votes" trial
and "I tried to overthrow
the government" trial.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
So, I just want to say,
even if you're a fan,
that's a lot of trials.
-(LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE)
-So we thought...
since the chances are very good
that he will get convicted
of one of these,
we thought as a public service,
because we're always
about the public service here,
we would put out
a little pamphlet called,
"Tips for Donald Trump's
Cellmate".
He's probably gonna have
a cellmate.
So these are things
you might want to look out for
if you are, you know,
if you're the person
who becomes
Donald Trump's cellmate.
Don't believe him when he says
how many cigarettes he's worth.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Explain to him
that he's not allowed
conjugal visits
from his daughter.
(LAUGHTER, GROANING)
He loves compliments,
so tell him,
"That jumpsuit really
brings out your orange."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Don't-- Don't be surprised
if one of his cavity searches
turns up Sean Hannity.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
When he begs
some Mexican inmates
to help him get over the wall,
refrain from pointing out
the obvious irony.
(LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE)
Let him know that singing
Y.M.C.A. in the shower
might send the wrong signal.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Don't get aggravated
when he keeps referring to
his one phone call as "perfect."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
He's a big eater,
so don't be surprised
when he takes a shiv
and makes it into a spoon.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
And finally, when he offers--
when he offers to blow you
for a Diet Coke,
make sure you get
the blow job first.